uh in westminster and in the battle of
the deputies today sam what are you
expecting
well it's the longest period where the
prime minister's been out of the country
i think since the 1970s so yes angela
rainer for labor dominic raab for the
conservatives standing in for the prime
minister
i think that in the end angela rainer
likely to go uh on a couple of things
labor preferring in these exchanges
always to start off with cost of living
questions to make sure that they don't
face accusations that they're just
focusing uh on as the conservatives have
had it petty uh personal politics around
the the prime minister but there's no
way that angela rainer uh won't dig into
tory uh woes as the session goes on
there's a lot of turbulence in politics
at the moment uh don't forget this will
be the first prime minister's question
since the double by-election defeat for
the conservatives last thursday
if you remember uh they lost the
tiverton hollington by-election that
went to the liberal democrats huge
majority of the tories overturned by the
libtems richard ford there they also
lost the wakefield by-election uh to the
labour party it's like narrower uh win
for labour there but nevertheless two
bad results that would put people like
theresa villa's seat very much in doubt
if there's anything like those kinds of
swings
at a general election uh it has uh
caused a bit more jitters in the
conservative party um but they've been
so there's been so much else on the
agenda there haven't been moments where
that's really been reflected in
parliament or elsewhere
some of the things that have been sort
of dominating uh mp's lives this week
include the northern ireland protocol
bill that attempt to roll back parts of
the um brexit deal that boris johnson
agreed uh to uh remove some of those
checks on goods going from great britain
to northern ireland that's upset many uh
in the eu
you've had the issue of strikes
dominating still over the weekend that's
caused some difficulty uh for labor
what's their position on whether or not
they'd match in or offer
inflation-busting pay rises again that
hasn't been clear from members of the uh
labour party the smp's faced turmoil as
well over patrick grady uh who was
suspended for sexual misconduct in
blackford the labour the snp leader in
westminster coming under fire for some
of his support for patrick grady uh some
suggestions that he should be removed
from his post there's been an awful lot
going on quite a lot of of that i
suspect will come up at prime minister's
questions uh but in the end i suspect
that angela reynolds will want to take
dicks of the prime minister dominic rob
on his feet let's go over to the house
of commons on behalf of my right
honourable friend the prime minister he
attended the commonwealth heads of
government meeting in rwanda the g7
leader summit and today he's at the nato
summit in madrid
mr speaker i know that the thoughts of
the whole house will be with the family
and friends of dame deborah james
following the news of her death i lost
my father at a young age to cancer i
will know uh firsthand the pain that her
family must be feeling but we also know
that dame deborah was a huge inspiration
to so many and raised millions to help
others affected by cancer
andrew jones
nationally 52
of disabled people are in work compared
with 81 for non-disabled people
disability action yorkshire which is a
charity based in harrogate works to
close that gap and they have highlighted
the success of the access to work scheme
for example one young person having been
told you would never work is now thanks
to the targeted support available the
trainee brewer at roosters brewery
[Music]
so will my right honourable friend
consider how we can boost awareness
amongst employers of this access to work
scheme and also consider how we can
simplify the application process so more
disabled people don't get deterred and
will embrace it
[Music]
can i thank my honorable friend for
raising the work of disability action
yorkshire they're doing terrific work in
his constituency i can reassure him that
the dwp is committed to improving
awareness through campaigns and
partnerships with employers but also
disability organizations they're also
working uh specifically on a digital
service which will make it more
accessible and more visible
deputy leader angela reyna
thank you mr speaker and can i also
share with the deputy prime minister his
deepest condolences and his personal
experience as we mourn the loss of dame
deborah james who fearlessly campaigned
to inspire so many and i'm absolutely
sure there's no doubt that she saved the
lives of many more and to the family of
zara alina who was tragically murdered
this week on the streets of ilford well
mr speaker i also want to congratulate
the two honorable members the new
members who won in the by-elections this
week including my honorable friend the
member for wakefield
[Applause]
mr speaker this week the government lost
two by-elections in one day the first in
three decades it's no wonder that the
prime minister has fled the country and
left the honorable member to carry the
the people of wakefield and tifferinton
held their own vote of no confidence the
prime minister
isn't just losing the room mr speaker
he's losing the country
[Music]
but instead of showing some humility
intends to limp on until the 2030s
so does he think the cabinet will prop
him up for this long
prime minister i thank the right
honourable lady um i gently point out to
her that we want this prime minister to
go on a lot longer than she wants the
leader of the labour party
[Applause]
mr speaker we've got a working majority
of 75 we're focusing on delivering for
the british people record low
unemployment wouldn't it happen if we
listen to the labour party
more policing tougher sentencing in
force this week police courts crime and
sentencing act she voted against both so
do the labour party
and we'll will protect the public from
these damaging rail strikes when we've
got the the scene of labour front
ventures joining the picket lines
mr speaker here we go again but the
truth is what i want for my honorable
friend the leader of this opposition is
not to be the leader of the opposition
but to be the prime minister of this
country and to be honest mr speaker it
couldn't come quick enough britain can't
stop it this prime minister for another
eight years his own benches can't
stomach him for another eight minutes
and if they continue to prop him up mr
speaker i doubt the voters will stomach
him for even eight seconds in the ballot
box
now let's imagine mr speaker the prime
minister is still clinging on into the
2030s under this tax high low growth
tory government at this rate by 2030 the
british public will have endured 55 tax
risers
so how many more tax risers will this
government inflict on working families
before he says enough is enough
mr speaker i think she was right first
time
mr speaker i'll tell you what we're
doing record near record levels of youth
unemployment 3.8 unemployment
we're cutting taxes next month on
national insurance 330 million pounds
we're delivering for families through
the the difficult times of the cost of
living what about the labour party we
heard yesterday what their plan is
their plan is no plan the leader of the
labour party said he's wiping the slate
clean he's starting from scratch he's
only been in the job two years
so tony blair who's actually got some
experience of winning elections says
there's a gaping hole in labour's policy
offer and all the while
there's a there's a smile creeping over
her face all the while she's reveling in
it we're getting on with serving the
people of this country she's just
playing political games
mr speaker i'd revel in the opportunity
for the people of this country to have
more than just by-elections to see what
they think of this government
call a general election and see where
the people are mr speaker
and this is a man who once said high
levels of government taxation was
hurting uk competitiveness now he's
backing the prime minister who wants to
put taxes up 15 times at this rate mr
speaker working people will be paying
500 billion pounds more in tax by 2030.
how high
does he think the burden on working
people should get before he says enough
is enough
the prime minister we hope hey we're the
ones helping working people with a tax
cut with a tax cut of 330 pounds but
with
the
the support for those on the lowest
incomes with uh the
650 pounds support for 8 million on the
lowest incomes
and with frankly the record level of
investment coming into this country from
the 1 billion by moderna for vaccines to
the highest level tech investment in
europe according to atomico we are the
ones with a plan for low unemployment a
high wage a high skill economy at labor
it's back to year zero yeah
angela rainer the speaker if he tends to
emphasize with those struggling with the
tory cost of living crisis when it was
he himself who once said that food bank
users are not in poverty but simply have
a cash flow problem the only remember
doesn't he spent over a million pound in
nine months on private jets it shows how
out of touch this government is mr
speaker but at this rate by 2030 a
million more people will be using food
banks how many more working people will
be pushed into poverty by his prime
minister before he says enough is enough
i'll tell you if the labour party if the
right honourable lady wants to help
working people they should be clear in
standing up against these militant
reckless strikes
[Applause]
the right honourable lady has
flip-flopped the right honourable lady
has flip flop all over the place when it
came to these strikes first she said
they were lose-lose
then she tweeted workers that were left
with no choice when she was asked by the
bbc straight question she's normally a
straight shooting uh politician do you
like the rmt she said i'm going to have
to go now i've got a train to catch
[Laughter]
[Applause]
she talks about working people
she talks about working people
she talks about working people where was
the right honourable lady when the
comrades were on the picket line last
thursday
where was she when the labour front
bench were joining them rather than
standing up for the public
she was at the glenborn music festival
sipping champagne
listening to oprah champagne socialism
is back in the labor party
[Applause]
well well mr speaker that says a lot
about the party opposite i'll tell them
a few things about militancy it's this
government that are acting in a militant
way
and well they should have been at the
negotiating table they were at the
banqueting table getting hundreds of
thousands squeezed out of their donors
instead of dealing with a crisis and he
talks about traits no one could get
trained because of his failed transport
minister mr speaker and i tell you has a
stronger stomach
i think we'll just have a little quiet i
want to hear the question and you'll
also want to hear the answer angela
rainer
well mr speaker i think it's rather
ironic that you have to intervene
because of the being mob here when
they've got people through their noisy
protest laws being
protesting out on the street that they
give mr speaker they don't like it when
the public say what they think of them
but i tell you the honourable gentleman
opposite has a stronger stomach than his
colleagues behind him or on
honestly i want to be the question i
want to be the answer and i hate to say
it so do your constituents think about
them for once instead of yourselves
angela reyna
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker and when they were
asked about the absent prime minister's
plans to stick around until 2030 one
honorable member opposite said he'd lost
the plot
another one said with anyone with half a
brain would realize how dire things are
and a former conservative leader said
that the country would be better off
under new leadership and now the prime
minister
is at war with his own defense secretary
after confirming he will break his
manifesto pledge and increase in defense
spending
under this government britain is set to
have less troops less planes and less
ships the only thing the prime
minister's
interested in is defending his own job
just how many more troops have to lose
their jobs before he finally says enough
is enough
deputy prime minister thank you mr
speaker um in fact there's a 24 billion
pound increase for armed forces spending
on the armed forces is rising to 2.3 of
gdp again making us the largest military
spender in europe and frankly we'll take
no lessons from the right honourable
lady when it comes to this country first
thing she did when she became an mp 2016
voted against trident leaving us exposed
and uh she was campaigning for the right
honourable member facing to north to be
prime minister someone who would take us
out of nato
[Applause]
mr speaker talking about nato where was
the honorable member when the situation
in afghanistan on a sun lounger that's
where the honourable member was i take
no lectures from the honourable member
when it comes to doing your job
[Applause]
the prime minister said he felt no shame
over the by-election defeats he said his
government have been quite exceptional
well i agree that they've been
exceptional all right an exceptional
record on stagnant wages rising poverty
and broken promises and the prime
minister wants to drag this out until
2030s and how much more can he stomach
before he finds the guts mr speaker how
many more tax risers how many more
families drove into poverty and how many
manifesto pledges broken i hope for the
sake of the british public mr speaker
that we never find out and when will the
deputy prime minister finally grow a
backbone and tell the prime minister the
game is up
[Applause]
mr speaker i can't help thinking that my
honourable lady is auditioning for the
leadership contest on that side not
really referring to anything on this
side
[Applause]
well
she's
well she's she's got the support of the
honourable member
i'll tell you what we're doing we're
putting in place the policies to grow
our economy to help that
mr murray
we've had a good
questions already for scotland it's not
continued it's not your debate come on
mr speaker he was just announcing his
support for the right honourable lady in
the forthcoming
we're putting in places the economic
plan to help people with the cost of
living the labor leader is getting ready
for year zero we're the ones supporting
ukraine with sanctions on russia with
military support the honourable lady
voted to uh abolish uh trident we're the
ones making the streets safer more
police and tougher sentencing under the
police crime sentencing act in force
this week she voted against both they
got no plan they're not fit together mr
speaker boris
thank you mr speaker mr speaker the eden
project north has been five years of my
parliamentary life we've gone through
three prime ministers four chancellors
a plethora of ministers but know what
we've got to the point is i've got to
the point is that the leveling up bid is
going to go in very shortly we've got a
shovel ready plan we've got full
planning permission
does my right honourable friend agree
with me it is money worth spending in
morgan
this mr speaker honourable friend there
is no greater more tenacious campaigner
than the honourable member for his
constituents um he'll know
i can't discuss the details of any
specific bids but the next round of
funding allocations will be announced in
the autumn so we won't have to wait too
much longer
leader of the smp ian black
thank you mr speaker can i associate
myself with the remarks of the deputy
prime minister the deputy leader of the
labour party at the sad death of dame
deborah james our thoughts and prayers
are with her family at this trying time
and we thank her for all that she has
done to raise money for anti-cancer
mr speaker
scotland's first minister has set the
date
and started the campaign
our nation
will have its independence referendum on
the 19th of october
2023.
the reality is scotland has already paid
the price
for not being independent westminster
governments we did not vote for imposing
policies we don't support breaking
international law dragging scotland
three damaging brexit we didn't vote for
and delivering deep austerity cuts
contrast that with our european
neighbors who have greater income
equality lower poverty rates and higher
productivity mr speaker why not scotland
in the weeks and months ahead we will
make the positive case for independence
will the opposition if they can
make the case for continued westminster
rule here
give me prime minister thank you thank
you honorable gentleman it's always good
to see him in his place
no no genuinely it's good to see him in
his place it's not the right time for
another referendum given the challenges
that we face as one united kingdom and i
think and he referred to some of the
challenges in scotland but i think
actually the people of scotland want
their two governments to work together
and we are
keen willing enthusiastic to do so
ian blackfoot there is no case for the
union as we've just heard from the
deputy prime minister because
mr speaker the harsh reality is that the
tories might fear democratic debate but
they don't have the right to block
scottish democracy
as the
late
cannon kenyon wright said
what if the other voice we all know so
well responds by saying
we say no
we are the state
his answer
will we say yes
and we are the
people just
last year
the member for murray
the leader of the scottish conservatives
no less put it in his own words
a vote for the scottish national party
is another vote for an independent
referendum well
you won't often hear me say this but i
agree with him and so do the scottish
people scottish democracy will not be a
prisoner of any prime minister in this
place
so why is the uk government scared of
democracy or is it simply is it simply
that they have run out of ideas to
defend the failing westminster system
deputy prime minister i thank the
honourable gentleman i think he's rather
airbrushing history with uh that long
soliloquy but look he wrench mentioned
the problems that scotland faces uh huge
tax burden imposed by the smp
the the scotland's record on science and
maths uh under the international pisa
rankings are now uh have dropped below
england and wales and the snp have
presided of the worst drug death rate in
europe the highest since records began i
think the people of scotland expect
their government in hollywood and in
westminster to work together to tackle
the issues facing them in their
day-to-day lives
peter alders
thank you very much mr deputy speaker
there are great opportunities
[Applause]
there are mr speaker great opportunities
to create exciting new jobs in
low-carbon energy along the east anglian
coast and east coast college are up for
the challenge of providing local people
with the necessary skills however they
and other colleges are finding it
increasingly difficult to recruit and
retain teachers in such work as
fabrication engineering and construction
will my right honourable friend ensure
that the government come up with a
cross-departmental strategy to address
this staffing crisis in our further
education colleges which could undermine
the leveling up agenda obviously
deputies there come on
my underworld friend is absolutely right
and that's why we're investing nearly 52
million pounds to support the sector
recruiting and retaining excellent staff
and in particular looking and focusing
on the experience and the skills that we
can often find in industry to train the
next generation of technical experts
thank you mr speaker no country that
values its independence and indeed its
self-respect could agree to a treaty
which signed away its economic
independence and self-government
ultimately membership of any union that
involves pooling of sovereignty can only
be sustained with the consent of the
people does the deputy prime minister
agree with the prime minister and his
predecessor yes or no yeah
deputy prime minister i just say to
donald trump that's why we had the
referendum in uh a few years ago the
people of scotland spoken and
and we think it's not the right time to
be relitigating this issue
john berlin
thank you uh um mr speaker
speaking with lord ahmed yesterday
i thank the government for now listening
and allowing
high-risk british council contractors
still in afghanistan to be processed
immediately upon their application to
the citizenry settlement scheme and not
having to wait a further two months
until the application window closes
with taxation
at a 40-year high
when will the government be bolder in
cutting taxes given all the evidence the
world over shows that lower taxes
increases prosperity raises living
standards and better enables the
government to help the less fortunate
even if such a policy means cutting
spending such as hs2
[Applause]
my honourable friend makes an important
point about driving growth in the
economy and that's why
we're uh cutting taxes with the 130
super deduction for capital investment
that will not just create good jobs but
well-paid jobs and better paid jobs by
boosting productivity that's why we're
increasing the employment allowance
which represents a tax cut of a thousand
pound for half a million small
businesses that's why we've provided
business rate relief of seven billion
over the next five years and of course
we're cutting national insurance just
next month worth 330 pounds for a
typical employee
patricia gibbs thank you mr speaker as
torrey msp myrtle fraser points out
scotland has a third of britain's
landmass half its territorial waters
over 60
of uk fishing zones 98 of oil reserves
63 of natural gas a quarter of europe's
offshore wind resources and 90 percent
of the uk's fresh water
can the deputy prime minister explain
if his opposition to scottish
independence is because he fears the
loss of these invaluable resources
she's absolutely right in what she just
said there are huge assets right across
scotland and that's why we think we're
stronger together in delivering and
delivering for the people of scotland
oliver hill yeah
mr speaker
the deputy prime minister will be aware
that in northeast hertfordshire we have
some of the best farmland in the country
and at a time when there are concerns
about uh food production food security
at a time when the government is
considering rural land use
isn't it time to ensure that our
productive farmland isn't covered in
solar plants and that they are that they
are positioned rather on brownfield
sites on buildings and on low-grade
agriculture
[Applause]
i think he he makes a powerful point and
our 2023 land use framework will set out
our priorities for land use across the
country and he's right that we've got to
protect uh the most versatile
agricultural land and any plans a plans
for ground-mounted solar installations
will have to take that very point into
account his point is well made rosie
duffy
so far this year 52 women have been
killed in the uk
our rights to free speech safe spaces
fairness in sport and even the words we
use to describe our own bodies are all
under threat will the deputy prime
minister send a clear signal as some of
his cabinet colleagues have done this
week that britain respects the rights of
women and will he accept the cross-party
amendment to his forthcoming bill of
rights which enshrines a woman's right
to choose in law
deputy prime minister can i thank the
honourable lady um for a question can i
also just say at the outset what huge
respect i personally have for her with
the way she stood up for women's rights
and frankly the appalling harassment
trolling and bullying that she's faced
the position as she knows is settled in
uk law in relation to abortion it's
decided by honourable members uh across
this house it's an issue of conscience i
don't think there is a strong case for
change what i wouldn't want to do uh is
find ourselves with a greater respect in
the u.s position where this is being uh
litigated through the courts rather than
settled as it is now settled uh by
honorable members in this house well
thank you mr speaker
in february 2019 the
this house uh passed my excellent civil
partnerships marriages and deaths
etc act mandating government to extend
civil partnerships to opposite sex
couples enabling marriage records to
include mother's details and requiring
the justice secretary to produce a
report empowering coroners to
investigate stillbirths the first two
have come into force very successfully
but two and a half years on despite
further shocking revelations about
deaths of babies at several hospitals no
report has yet been published nor
regulations to give coroners the powers
they need why not
minister can i thank my honourable
friend he's absolutely right to raise
this and of course stillbirth is an
appalling tragedy which has the most
devastating impact on families across
the country he's right the moj the dhsc
have jointly consulted on proposals to
provide coroners with new powers in this
regard i have looked at this personally
we will be publishing the government's
response to the consultation very
shortly
illumina
thank you mr speaker
threatened
terrified
alone
this was how survivors of sexual
violence told me they felt when they
were pressured into signing
non-disclosure agreements and gagging
clauses by their universities
no victim of sexual assault or
harassment should ever be coerced into
silence by the very institutions who are
meant to protect them not at university
not at work
not anywhere
so will the government back my bill to
ban the use of ndas in cases of sexual
harassment bullying and misconduct and
will the deputy prime minister consider
meeting with me in his role as justice
secretary to discuss how we'll put a
stop to this deplorable practice once
and for all
every prime minister can i just say
honorable lady i'll look very carefully
at
any particular proposal she has we've
got to do everything we can to protect
women and girls in this country and also
frankly to make them feel more confident
in the justice system that's why i'm
relieved but rest to go further but
relieved that the volume of rape
convictions in the last year alone is up
by two-thirds
and of course in the police courts
sensing a crime act in force this week
we have taken extra measures for example
by extending the time limit for
reporting domestic abuse and also
criminalizing uh taking photos of a
of a mother breastfeeding without
consent and i'll certainly look at the
proposals that she's raised with me
daniel
thank you mr speaker
we are investing nearly 190 billion
pounds this year into the nhs and yet
many of us
see disturbing deficiencies within nhs
management no more so than in the
shrewsbury and telford nhs trust
four years ago in 2018 my right
honourable friend the member for ludlow
and i secured 312 million pounds for a
major amd modernization within our local
hospital trust
four years on construction has still not
started what message can the deputy
prime minister give to the people of
shrewsbury as to how government can
intervene to break this gridlock and
finally allow the 312 million pounds we
have secured to be utilized for the
benefits of the people of shropshire and
mid wales
my honourable friend is a doubting
champion of his constituents
particularly on nhs services the dhsc
recently received the strategic outline
case uh for the transformation of any
services in truespin telford it's still
being processed but i can tell him that
the trust is aiming to present the full
business case in 2023 with construction
starting in the same year there's
several robots
when he announced his bill of rights
last week
the deputy prime minister said it will
strengthen our uk
tradition of freedom
freedom
shameless from a government whose
condemned for the rule of law and
evolution can be judged in equal measure
they're scrapping welsh law against our
will denying scotland the right to
choose their own future that isn't
freedom
will he will he prove me wrong will he
prove me wrong
by enshrining
self-determination in his bill of rights
[Music]
can i thank the honourable lady i
thought it's very deaf the way she got
that in i think we've all heard actually
across
the benches today the case for
reinforcing free speech uh whether it's
the judge made privacy laws or some of
the
way people are shouted down when they
express legitimate opinions and i also
think that the people of wales want to
join with us as a true across the
country making sure we can deport more
foreign national offenders that is the
reality for the people in wales and
across the united kingdom and i think
the bill of rights will be strengthening
our tradition of freedom but also
curbing those abuses and making sure we
inject a bit more common sense into the
system
thank you mr speaker derriford hospital
then my constituency is part of the new
hospital build program announced by this
government and work on new emergency
department actually starts this year
which is a significant investment for
the amazing staff there and the
brilliant chief executive and james who
works so hard but given the incredible
pressures on the real estate in
development would my original friend
consider prioritizing capital investment
into that part of the uk to ensure that
we can accelerate these plans
particularly in digital so that people
in health in plymouth get the
world-class healthcare they deserve
thank you honourable friend look he's
absolutely right um and the the this is
the largest hospital building program in
a generation and his constituents are
going to benefit very directly i can
tell him that there will be a new
integrated emergency care hospital
scheme for university hospitals plymouth
nhs trust at the derriford emergency
care hospital and yes on tech he's
absolutely right the facilities will be
at the cutting edge of modern technology
and that will really help drive up the
quality of patient care girlfriends
thank you mr speaker the victims of
black cab rapist john warboys were only
able to challenge the police's failures
to investigate its appalling crimes
because of the human rights act
they would not have been able to do so
under the deputy prime minister's new
so-called bill of rights
why does he want to stop women like the
victims of john warboys from making sure
the police protect them from rape and
sexual assault and getting the justice
they deserve
can i thank your honourable lady for the
opportunity that it was not the result
of litigation uh that uh addressed the
problems with the warboy case and indeed
uh if she wants to look after victims in
cases like that and others the labour
party should join with us not just in
supporting the bill of rights but our
parole reforms that will make sure
dangerous offenders are not released and
we protect the public
david
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker my constituent joel lindop
has suffered the abduction of his young
children
to poland one of
many families in the uk who go through a
similar experience every year
and despite repeated judgments in his
favor in the courts in poland
he's been unable to persuade the polish
authorities to fulfill their obligations
under international law
and return
those children to their family well my
right honourable friend intercede and
ensure that my constituent and the many
other families who face this challenge
are able to ensure that their children
are returned safely and in a timely
fashion in the future
honourable friend look uh i can't
imagine how appalling that situation
must be for any parent uh to find
themselves in he'll know we're committed
to the uh 1980 hay convention on child
abduction and that does provide a
mechanism he's right that that's one
that has to be driven through the courts
uh and that's not something we can
directly interfere on but i will make
sure and i'll speak to the foreign
office and see if the minister can
address whether there's anything further
that we can properly do to support him
i guess brandon might do thank you very
much mr speaker a serious question on
the conduct of the government that
regards three trade agreements and i
cannot understate the fury of the
international trade committee this
morning that led us to unanimously empty
chair the secretary of state for
international trade the government has
broken its word to the committee to the
house and to you mr speaker on scrutiny
of the australian trade deal by
triggering qrag and now endangering a
committee report it is the unanimous
view of the committee mr speaker tori
labour snp dup
that krag should be delayed allow proper
scrutiny as was promised will the
government deliver on its promise and
therefore delay craig
i am the prime minister i understand mr
speaker the secretary of state for um uh
international trade has agreed to come
back and address the committee just as
soon as possible
mr speaker i was privileged last week to
attend the malaria summit in kigali
even today malaria remains the biggest
single killer of mankind ever and 1.7
billion people are living every day
under its shadow of misery
but mr speaker we're on the cusp of
something really special and that recent
advances education and our british world
leading vaccines can now eradicate it
forever
can my right with friends please confirm
that the uk will fulfill its full
commitment to the global fund
prime minister can i thank my uh
honourable friend and i know from work
at the foreign office just how uh
powerful the global fund is it's a very
high performing international
organization uh he will know that since
2002 we've been the third largest donor
so we've stepped up to the plate the uh
the uk hasn't yet determined our pledge
for the seventh replenishment but i know
the foreign secretary will have heard
loud and clear the uh the advocacy that
he's made in their regard final question
bel ribeiro abby thank you thank you mr
speaker in their efforts to pursue a
hostile environment the home office
routinely tears families apart and
breaks human rights and equalities
legislation they're reported to be
sending yet another charter deportation
flight to nigeria and ghana in pride
month they'll be deporting lgbt asylum
seekers fleeing homophobia and
grandmothers and mothers of british
children who have lived in this country
for over 25 years given that the home
office repeatedly get it wrong and end
up having to take people off these
flights can the deputy prime minister
tell me how many people have been
removed from this flight already and
when will they stop these inhumane
deportation charter flights
well thank you everybody did you look
she's right right at least in one
respect of course uh people who come
here need to be treated decently and
humanely we're absolutely committed to
that um we also need to make sure uh
that uh um that we cut down the illegal
routes those that are here committed
serious offences could be returned home
and the crucial thing and i'm working
with the home sector is to make sure we
do both of those things but we can't
allow these illegal routes to flourish
into this country otherwise we'll just
attract more and we cannot allow people
who commit serious offences in this
country to stay and continue to pose a
threat to the public
ends questions
so you've just been hearing a weekly
prime minister's questions this week
with dominic rob the deputy prime
minister and angela rainer the deputy
lady libra lead labour leader because of
course boris johnson is at the nato
summit of leaders in madrid right now
let's bring in our deputy political
editor sam coats who's been watching
that for us live in westminster so a
pretty feisty exchange between the two
sam
yes pretty much all uh light not much
heat uh i didn't particularly think the
uh exchanges between angela and dominic
raab uh shed any light pretty much on
anything i thought the most important
bit of prime minister's questions was
something completely different
um and it is how the british response to
that important u.s supreme court ruling
last friday on the women's right to
abortion in the u.s the overturning of
roe v wade is playing out in british
politics now there is a growing momentum
from labour mps like stella creasy and
rosie duffield to put down in law uh an
amendment uh that would protect women's
right to abortion okay
i'm sorry to interrupt you we have to go
back to the house of commerce into the
international trade secretary and reach
rebellion a strategic steel industry is
of the utmost importance to the uk
especially given the uncertainty of
political and economic waters that we
are currently all charting
trade remedies are one of the ways that
government can protect their businesses
they tackle issues of dumping of unfair
government subsidies or as in the case
of safeguards give businesses time to
adjust to unforeseen